so a new Challenger has entered the
tournament and it is being powered by
two of the big names from po spinning
and flow Arts back in the early 2000s so
is flow arts. going to remake the flow
Arts world let's talk about
it Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love po spinning and flow
Arts to benefit your body and brain and
in this video we're going to talk a
little bit about a brand new website and
the impact that it may or may not have
on the flow Arts but before we dive in I
just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys pyrro Tera light toys and Ultra poy
for helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links down in the the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non-b buus friend of the channel Becca
beckon thank you so much for supporting
my channel my work and my mission all
right so first up a little bit of
context here I think it's safe to say
that we've hit a wave of nostalgia for a
period in the flow Arts that kind of
existed before the Advent of social
media I've seen a lot of people online
yearning for the days when we were
exchanging information via online forums
such as home of Po spheris and tribe and
calling for the Resurgence of these kind
of forums because as we all know a lot
of the conversations in places like
Facebook and even Instagram can turn out
to be well pretty ranker if we're not
careful and I think it does need to be
said that probably the biggest sign that
we have hit this wave of nostalgia is
that Nick Wolsey has come out of
retirement the granddad of Po who taught
us all how to do it back in the late
2000s and early
2010s is back on a brand new workshop
tour and uh has become really active
online and is in fact one of the key
players in this new website the other
major player involved in this is a guy
named Matt Terry who once upon a time
was really famous for doing a type of
contact pyric called a Wibble and who
later was instrumental in starting up a
website called spheris which was one of
the alternatives to home of po that
existed back in the day and one of those
spots that the more advanced and
technically minded po Spinners tended to
gravitate towards so now these two have
combined their powers and Matt Terry has
put up a brand new website called flow
arts. that is designed to bring back a
lot of those experiences of the old web
forums into a brand new package and Nick
wisey is jumping on for the ride uh in
fact one of the biggest ways that
they're promoting this this website is
that you can get access to Nick's
beginner course on the website itself
and it does need to be said right now
there's not a whole lot of stuff on the
website it's basically just a landing
page where you sign up for an account
and you can get a sample video from
Nick's tutorial series and there are
some forums that are also available
there's not a whole lot in them just yet
it appears that the way that they're
funding this website is that you get
access to Nick's course if you sign up
for a subscript
I have absolutely no idea what
percentage of that subscription fee goes
to the website what percentage of it
goes to Nick but it does appear that
this is the income model for the website
and right now about half of the
website's features are kind of hidden
behind that pay wall okay so is this
going to ride the wave of nostalgia and
bring back all the old heads and some of
the new ones hopefully or is this going
to be a flash in the pen that will
disappear um short answer is I don't
really know so I don't think that we
should underestimate the amount of
energy that's coming up behind the
Nostalgia wave in flow Arts again it's
been really shocking to me but in the
past couple years I've heard a lot of
people online yearning for what they
consider to be the Glory Days of those
online forums and I think both Matt
Terry and Nick woy are well positioned
to kind of ride that wave of nostalgia
so I'm going to say I think probably the
biggest thing that this website is going
to need in order to be a success is that
it needs to have something free that
people can engage with that provides
some amount of value and makes them
interested in signing up for more of the
paid services and no I don't think the
Forum on its own is going to be enough
to do that see just showing up to the
website and having the only thing there
being a little form for you to log in or
sign up for a new account um you're
going to get the vast majority of people
who are showing up they're just turning
right back around cuz there there's
nothing there for them thanks to social
media we are long past the time when you
don't have to offer something to people
to keep them engaged before getting them
to sign up for the rest of a website's
features I'm also going to say that the
website itself has some rough edges
especially on mobile there are some
aspects of the stylesheet that kind of
make it difficult to read sections of it
or difficult to navigate different
things and who knows maybe for some
folks again have that Nostalgia for the
early 2000s period of uh kind of poed
discourse online that will be a feature
instead of a bug but for me using it it
kind of takes me out of the user
experience for a moment and the more of
those bugs that I encounter and the more
difficulties that I have kind of just
interacting with the website that makes
me less likely to come back and use it
again on the plus side I think that
hosting Nicks beginner course is a great
tie-in for this website and working off
of a subscription-based monetary model I
think is better than you know just
buying the course one off if for no
other reason then I think it's going to
mean that the income stream for that
website and thus the stability of it and
the ability to keep on developing it is
going to be way more stable than it
would be just doing oneoff purchases I'm
definitely going to keep checking in the
next few days to see how it evolves and
if you out there are interested I will
include a link to it down in the
description you can go sign up for your
own accounts check out the forums see
what's what and see what you think of
flow arts. do you have Nostalgia for
that old web Forum format of having
online flow Arts discourse what was your
favorite website to go to and what do
you miss about it leave me a comment and
let me know and also too leave me some
feedback and let me know what you think
of this video it was kind of an
experiment um just kind of responding in
the moment to something that was
breaking news in the flow Arts giving
some background on it and sharing my
thoughts just off the top of my head do
you enjoy this kind of on thepot stuff
uh or would you rather see me develop an
entire video essay on something like
this leave me a comment and let me know
also be sure to like share and subscribe
to help other people find the video and
of course to help my channel grow
this video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on patreon and in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you all so much
you rock and if you out there watching
appreciate the content that I create and
you want to see me make more of it the
best way to do that is to sign up to
support these videos on patreon
specifically you can head on over to
patreon.com drexfactor poy and sign up
there you can get access to a whole host
of awesome rewards but even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring po spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world go check
that out please and thank you and
speaking of Nick Wy would you love to
learn more about his career and the
impact that he has had on the flow Arts
I did an entire video essay on that last
year that I'll go ahead and link to up
on screen as well as down in the
description thank you so much for
watching make sure to get out and flow
yourselves today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon take care now peace